هنا الجفاف يدق ناقوس الخطر قاع السدود
المائيه الاردنيه وصلاح حد التصحر اماني
والمشهد يعكس وضع ازمه البلاد المائيه
موسم مطري جديد استطاع تغيير المشهد في
السدود التي وصلت نسبه المياه فيها ما
يقارب 75 مليون متر مكعب
الوجهه سد الموجب الذي يعتبر احد اهم
السدود في الجنوب الاردني واكثر من عالم
من مشكله قله الامطار وما تلاها من جفاف
الا ان المنخفض الاخير اعاد نسبه تخزين
المياه فيه الى ما يقارب 80% من طاقته
الاستيعابيه له طول المطر وصل الى حوالي
38.5% من المعدل السنوي العام للهطول
المطر اللي هو 8-1 بالعشره مليار متر مكعب
وهو افضل مما كنا العامل الماضي ويشكل من
العام الماضي كاملا 49.5% فهذه نسبه جيده
وضعوا حارج مره على البلاد اخذت منه
السدود الحصه الاكبر العام الماضي وما
عوده المياه الى الس بكميات لم تصل ربما
لحل الازمه المائيه في البلاد حلول اخرى
فرضت نفسها كمشاريع الحصاد المائيه من
خلال جمع المهدور من مياه الامطار في حفر
مجهزه باتت فرصه يستثمرها اصحاب القطاع
الزراعي ومربي المواشي
اكثر من 26 حفره وسدا ترابيا مهمتها تجميع
مياه الامطار في المناطق الاكثر تاثرا
بالجفاف اضافه لامداد الابار الجوفيه من
مياهها عبر ما يعرف بشحن المياه الجوفيه
تغير مناخ الان يتم مجابهته بزياده
الحصائد المائي والحفائر الترابيه والسدود
وايضا زياده الغطاء النباتي بزياده
الغابات الموجوده على اطراف هذه الحفار
يتم استثمارها بالمناطق التي يمكن انك
تزيد الغطاء النباتي فيها بحيث انك تكافح
موضوع تغير المناخي الخضرا بندوره خيار
همم كل الخضار هذه الصيفيه هذه كلها
نستفيد منها نستفيد منها للحلال ونستفيد
منها للبشر ونبيع
امتلاء السدود ونجاح مشاريع الحصاد
المائيه يبقى الرهان وعلى موسم مطري يتمنى
الجميع ان ينتهي بفره الامطار كما كانت
بدايته من محافظه الكرك جنوب العاصمه عمان
عماد العضله العربيه